[Music]
what's going on mtv this is chris ultimo
right here i want to uh introduce myself
to you today right now because people
keep on coming up to me they keep on
telling me hey chris you should audition
for this thing so i'm just going to tell
you right now this is my official
audition for your public service
announcement
aka the jersey shore
about to take you guys on a tour
tour of our studio actually not
necessarily our studio more like a tour
of the most important part of the studio
my desk
that's about it it's a long hallway we
don't have to keep on recording the
entire hallway
[Music]
you're still recording aren't you this
is the ulta desk person who sits next to
me show how witty i am check this out we
decided to make a analog version of
facetime you know the iphone thing chris
ultimo on another desk what are you
gonna do about it
check this out let me give you a lot of
proof them from the jersey shore
first off you can find my wallet i'm
very proud of being sicilian this is my
sicilian map and point out where my
family is from the from barcelona which
is somewhere around here
somewhere between this cool thing and uh
and this thing right here check out that
slick cart right there and see how mr
dude right here is all chilling with
these mamasitas in the back if i was in
the 1800s i'd be riding around in this
thing that would be the oldsmobile in
the past the truth is i actually do keep
on me at my desk at all times
jewelry cleaner and jewelry polish
and i do this because sometimes you go
to a club after work or you don't know
you're gonna go to a club it could be a
wednesday let's say and you don't know
you're about to go to a club but then
you get a call from a chiquita and she's
all like hey let's go out to like the
standard tonight and i'll be like all
right well now i'm ready because i got
all the shine to go on right here not
only i also keep gym clothes with me at
all times i belong to three gyms one at
warner brothers
one at my apartment complex which is
open 24 hours and another one gold's gym
right in downtown
you maybe you should join one i'm gonna
show you how much of a heartthrob i am
get ready anywhere i go around the
office people just go crazy over me
how you doing baby
good
good see she's speechless she doesn't
know what else to say around me right
now
i'm at my place of business right now
where i do my working and stuff and you
know what i'm here for you know i am a
pa on the show but also i am the
official party planner that's what we're
about to do right now we have a party
what's going on everybody what it's a
very good website you're a very good
judge of websites
you're very good at your work too people
work so much better when i'm around so
what do you think jersey shore people
work better when i'm around you're doing
a good job fighting situation in snooki
that's right keep on fighting i'm an
enabler that's what i'm here for that's
what i'm gonna do if you let me on the
show i'm gonna enable you
to make more episodes of said show so
mtv to sum it all up
let me help you that's the entire point
of this entire video
i'm da vinci let me paint the mona lisa
that is a jersey shore
that's it